ha defendido la política de Cero covid
en el discurso de inauguración del
congreso del partido comunista dicho sí
que su gobierno ha priorizado las vidas
humanas y ha conseguido los mejores
resultados en prevención y control de la
pandemia así no se ha referido a los
efectos colaterales el hastío del pueblo
la factura económica o el aislamiento
del país esa política es ahora el mayor
problema de China solo es viable a corto
plazo pero china no puede levantarla
porque la precaria red de sanidad en las
zonas Rurales quedaría devastada y
Shanghai ya demostró que la tercera vía
tampoco es viable los tres editoriales
que había encadenado esta semana El
Diario del pueblo defendiendo la
política ya sugerían que no habría
cambios en este congreso Sí también se
ha referido a Taiwán dice que Las ruedas
del tiempo giran hacia la reunificación
la prioridad ha añadido es la
reunificación pacífica pero Se reserva
el uso de la fuerza si no hay otro
remedio es la postura oficial mil veces
repetidas pero había interés en saber si
sí la iba a variar después de las
últimas provocaciones de Estados Unidos
el discurso de sí ha transitado por
lugares comunes como la lucha contra la
corrupción o la defensa del medio
ambiente no ha habido ninguna sorpresa
ya se esperaba en un congreso
continuista que servirá para que sí se
haga con un tercer mandato al frente del
partido comunista